hello everyone bonjour à tous
alors ça c'est une carte de crédit en
plastique c'est l'équivalent des cinq
grammes de plastique qu on en gère
chaque semaine
imaginez ce que ça peut donner sur toute
une vie
ce plastique mais il vient d'où il vient
des produits en plastique recyclé ou en
plastique qu'on consomme et qu'on
produit chaque jour
lorsqu'on met bout à bout tous les
événements climatiques catastrophiques
de cet été
les incendies de forêt en turquie en
grèce ou dans le sud de la france les
inondations sans précédent en belgique
en chine a new york la canicule au
canada on se dit qu'on en est presque
dans un film de superproductions
apocalyptique mais malheureusement ce
n'est pas un film c'est bien la triste
réalité qui est devenu aujourd'hui
impossible à ignorer
le dernier rapport du giec nous confirme
encore les pires prévisions mais la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il est encore
temps d'agir il est encore temps de
repenser nos actions d' arrêter avec ce
déni ce désintérêt la sidération on peut
encore empêcher ces sombres prévisions
l'être humain est capable de temps même
de l'impossible
de multiples problèmes contribuer au
changement climatique on le sait tous
mais il y en a un très simple pour
lequel chacun de nous dans cette salle
on peut faire quelque chose dès demain
dès maintenant la pollution plastique
vous me direz mais quel est le lien
entre le changement climatique et la
pollution plastique
bien c'est très simple les débris qui
sont présents par millions dans
l'environnement et qui enlaidissent le
paysage se fragmente en de minuscules
fragments de moins de 5 mm sous l'effet
des rayons ultraviolets du soleil et de
l'oxydation on appelle ça les micro
plastiques une étude très intéressante
publiée aux etats-unis en août 2010 huit
amis en dvi ans pour la toute première
fois que la dégradation et la
décomposition de ces déchets plastiques
libère des gaz à effet de serre ce qui
veut dire concrètement que la pollution
plastique contribué inévitablement au
réchauffement climatique
voyez c'est assez simple et il est
important de le comprendre il est
important de le réaliser car aujourd'hui
l'océan détient à lui seul
80% des déchets plastiques de la planète
donc imaginez le niveau de gaz à effet
de serre que cela peut donner les
chercheurs ont fait des tests sur tous
les types produits comme il par exemple
les bouteilles les sacs les emballages
les produits industriels ils sont
arrivés à la conclusion que le
polyéthylène et l émetteur le plus
prolifique
le polyéthylène où on l'appelle pe aussi
landes et plastiques les plus répandues
dans le monde il sert à fabriquer des
objets moulés souvent jetables on
utilise notamment pour des bouteilles
d'eau
la bonne nouvelle c'est que si on prend
des mesures audacieuses
maintenant pour réduire la pollution
plastique et notre consommation nous
réduirons notre empreinte carbone et
l'empreinte carbone des gaz à effet de
serre produits par ces déchets
plastiques la pollution plastique est
aujourd'hui devenu l'un des plus grands
fléaux de notre temps ce n'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est l'onu mais revenons un
instant sur le point fondamental le
plastique au fond c'est quoi c'est un
matériau fantastique qui a été inventé
par l'homme pour durer pour durer très
longtemps beaucoup plus longtemps que
chacun d'où il peut être presque tout ce
qu'on veut solide souple résistants ou
même malléable à la chaleur
beaucoup pensent que si l'une des
inventions les plus extraordinaires de
l'humain
du coup nous l'avons introduit dans
toutes les industries dans tous les
produits autour de nous et nous en
produisons dans des quantités
inimaginaux
le plastique est aujourd'hui omniprésent
dans nos vies il y en a partout nous
vivons dans une époque où l'on touche
plus de plastique que les gens qu'on
aime
le plastique ne disparaît jamais même
lorsqu'il se dégrade l'homme redevient
poussière mais pas lui ils se
transforment en petites particules et
reste pour des siècles dans l'atmosphère
dans l'océan dans le sol
certains disent que nous sommes à l'ère
numérique
moi je dis que nous sommes à l'ère du
plastique
les générations futures qui étudieront
notre époque trouveront des plastiques
fossiles qu'ils exposeront dans des
musées d'archéologie pour illustrer
notre époque c'est un peu triste non on
en a d'ailleurs déjà trouvé de ces
plastiques fossiles c'est charles moore
qui a découvert par hasard en 2006 cette
nouvelle pierre fiat de plastique et
d'éléments naturels
avec ses collègues ils les ont appelés
le plastique glomerata depuis on en
découvre des millions et ce n'est que le
début
de 15 millions de tonnes en 1960 la
production du plastique a grimpé à un
rythme exponentiel pour s'établir à un
peu plus de 300 millions de tonnes
aujourd'hui dont environ 40% sont
destinés uniquement aux emballages
alors dans les chiffres
on nous dit que nous sommes passés de
367 millions de tonnes de plastique en
2020 contre 368 millions en 2019 et
qu'un tel recul dans la production de ce
matériau n'était pas arrivé depuis 1973
mais voilà ce recul on le doit
malheureusement pas à l'éveil mondial de
l'industrie
on le doit à la pandémie du corona bérus
et au confinement
c'est la troisième baisse mondiale
depuis l'après guerre
il ya donc eu 1973 au moment du premier
choc pétrolier puis 2008 lors de la
crise des subprimes et maintenant 2020
avec la crise du coronavirus et cela
nous dit quelque chose de très simple
c'est qu'il est possible de réduire
cette production il est possible de
réduire notre consommation de plastique
et donc de réduire les déchets qui
finiront dans l'environnement et cela
tombe bien parce qu'il est urgent de le
faire maintenant
l'accumulation des déchets dans
l'environnement et dans l'océan est
d'une ampleur sans précédent
et il n'est pas besoin de se rendre à
l'autre bout de la planète pour s'en
rendre compte
si on n'agit pas complètement maintenant
pas en 2030 pas en 2040 mais maintenant
la pollution plastique étouffera l'océan
et l'humain avec
notre planète bleue est tout simplement
emballé dans du plastique
un peu comme l'arc de triomphe
actuellement
ce problème ce n'est pas celui de tel ou
tel pays ce problème c'est le nôtre à
tous partout dans le monde quel que soit
notre couleur notre genre nos croyances
nos goûts et nos différences car c'est
la vie sur terre qui est menacée on sait
aujourd'hui que la pollution plastique
questions de pollution de l'air donc
même si tous les scientifiques ignorent
encore exactement toutes les maladies
que cette catastrophe sanitaire va
produire on sait oui on sait
qu'aujourd'hui cela provoque de l'asthme
le cancer et l'infertilité
et je pense que vous serez d'accord avec
moi que nous n'avons pas besoin d'en
savoir plus nous n'avons pas besoin
d'avoir encore une étude supplémentaire
pour nous dire et nous confirmer tout ça
pour agir
vous avez certainement entendu parler du
recyclage du plastique
on vous a certainement dit que le
plastique recyclé c'est la solution pour
régler ce problème est peut-être que
vous y croyez
au début comme vous j ai cru j'ai trouvé
cela formidable mais voilà c'est
totalement faux le plastique ne se
recyclent pas à l'infini comme le verre
l'aluminium ou le papier le pire c'est
qu'ils créent tout au long de son cycle
de vie des micro plastiques ou nano
plastique ces fameux micro plastiques
qu'on respire qu'on mange proviennent de
ses produits en plastique ou plastique
recyclé que nous produisons utilisons
encore et encore et encore
nous en sommes devenus tout simplement à
chrome
et c'est tout particulièrement le cas
pour ma génération est la vôtre inclus
nous avons du mal à nous séparer de
certains objets en plastique parce
qu'ils nous sont nostalgiques
ils sont liés à des traditions
familiales ils nous ont accompagnés dans
notre enfance
on a un rapport de dépendance à certains
objets plastiques comme par exemple
les ballons pour les anniversaires
les déguisements d'halloween les poupées
barbie les figurines marvel les lego les
sapins de noël artificiel bien sûr le
frisbee les scoubidous le rubik's cube
les ballons de foot tous ces objets en
plastique
c'est dur d'en faire le deuil alors on
continue on continue on transmet cette
addiction à nos enfants la boucle elle
doit s'arrêter avec vous
l'idée ce n'est pas de supprimer tout ça
mais de leur pensée il est temps qu'on
repense nos traditions nos fêtes nos
amusement pour une vie sans plastique
nous devons garder en ligne de mire
l'essentiel notre rôle dans l'écosystème
ce rôle n'est pas celui de dominer ou de
se croire au dessus de la nature nous
connaissons mille fois plus de choses
que nos ancêtres nous avons beaucoup
plus facilement accès à la connaissance
nous pouvons utiliser cette intelligence
pour créer un monde en harmonie avec la
nature pour l'aider à se régénérer pour
réparer les erreurs du passé
lorsqu'il ya eu le premier confinement
j'ai lu beaucoup d'articles qui venait
du tout le monde entier disant que la
terre respire et enfin que l'air était
pure qu'on voyait enfin pour la première
fois depuis trente ans les sommets de
l'himalaya en inde certains affirment et
même n'avoir jamais assisté à un tel
spectacle de leur vivant
pour ma part ces bonnes nouvelles elles
m'ont rendu triste
je me suis dit mais comment est il
possible qu'il faille ont fermé tous les
humains chez eux pour que la nature
puisse enfin re vivre et respirer
c'était comme si nous les humains étions
les intrus de cet écosystème les intrus
sur cette planète
pourtant nous ne sommes pas des intrus
nous faisons tout autant partie des
êtres vivants de cette planète nous y
avons vu le jour nous y avons notre
place nous avons simplement oublié que
nous faisions partie d'un tout vous que
nous sommes connectés à la nature que
nous faisons qu'un avec la planète
sans océans il n'y a pas de vie sans
océans il n'ya pas d'oxygène sans cette
planète bleue nous aurons vraiment du
mal à vivre sur cette planète on me
demande souvent comment peut-on agir
concrètement contre la pollution
plastique
la solution c'est avant tout de limiter
les futures pollution plastique et pour
cela il faut s'informer
s'informer c'est d'abord comprendre que
réintroduire le plastique dans nos vies
dans les mains de nos enfants pour un
nouveau cycle n'est pas la solution nous
n'arrêterons pas la pollution comme ça
informer c'est apprendre et comprendre
où se cache le plastique parce qu'il ya
les objets évident bien sûr qu'on
connaît tous comme la bouteille d'eau
les sacs en plastique les pailles et
puis elle est ce qu'on appelle les
plastiques cacher mais qui sont non
moins présent dans nos vies
les chewing gum les paillettes les
rouges à lèvres
les crèmes solaires les sachets de thé
les pneus le drapé de l'arc de triomphe
enfin je peux continuer comme ça toute
la journée nous devons repenser notre
mode de consommation
et ce n'est pas si compliqué les
solutions les alternatives elles
existent déjà et ce ne sont ni des
produits plus contraignant - efficace -
esthétique ou moins à la mode
combien de marque existe-t-il des ja qui
propose des articles désirable et ce en
plastique je vais vous le dire il y en a
beaucoup
et il y en a de plus en plus
je sais qu'il est difficile d'imaginer
une vie sans plastique mais c'est
vraiment nécessaire
je rêve d'un monde où j'irai faire du
shopping et que je n'aurai plus besoin
de vérifier si un produit contient ou
non du plastique car les marques les
industriels auront fait en sorte de les
bannir de nos rayons nous devons cesser
de vouloir absolument trouver comment
donner une autre vie aux déchets
plastiques
pourquoi pensons nous que c'est la seule
solution
pour agir nous devons aussi continuer à
ramasser tout le plastique temps qui
s'est encore possible alors je dis bien
tant que c'est encore possible car si on
attend trop longtemps à ces déchets
plastiques qui vont se dégrader en des
morceaux invisibles à l'oeil nu et ce
n'est pas parce qu'on le voit plus qu'il
n'existe plus
mais au lieu de refaire faire un cycle
de nuisance à ce plastique recyclé
investissons mettons en place des
structures pour l'éradiquer ou le
valoriser en énergie mais cessons d'en
refaire d'autres objets d'autres
produits vêtements en plastique qui
redeviendront inévitablement des déchets
plastiques quand vous serez dans la vie
active en poste dans des industries
gouvernement comme jeunes entrepreneurs
pensez-y et fait circuler l'information
au lieu d'investir des milliards dans le
recyclage on devrait investir dans la
mise en place d l'isolation des
solutions qui existent déjà pour qu'on
puisse les utiliser massivement de
manière industrielle pour lutter contre
cette pollution plastique
en 2018 une équipe de chercheurs a
découvert une enzyme une bactérie qui
serait capable détruire naturellement de
fortes quantités plastique en un temps
record en 2019 un jeune irlandais âgé de
18 ans a trouvé le moyen d'utiliser le
liquide magnétique de la nasa pour
éliminer les micro plastiques nocives de
l'eau vous voyez il ya plein d'espoir
dans l'innovation arrêtons de nous faire
croire qu'il n'est pas possible de faire
autrement dès à présent
les solutions elles sont déjà là bon
vous l'avez compris le recyclage du
plastique
ce n'est pas vraiment la solution
l'économie circulaire n'a de sens que si
c'est un cercle vertueux dans le cas
contraire le seul sens c'est celui de
l'économie
aujourd'hui vous qui êtes cette nouvelle
génération vous avez l'avenir entre vos
mains et ce ne sont pas que des mots
nous sommes à un tournant sans précédent
dans l'histoire de l'humanité et vous
avez la chance de pouvoir remettre au
centre des innovations à venir
la nature je suis sûr que dans cette
salle chacun de vous a la capacité de
changer le monde
chaque génération s'imagine être plus
intelligente que celles d'avant est plus
sage que celle qui vient mais la vérité
c'est que chaque génération a tendance à
oublier que la nature est pleine de
surprises et plein d'intelligence c'est
en devenant des humains échos conscients
qu'ils intègrent l'intelligence de la
nature que vous gagnerez en intelligence
et que vous changerez le monde pour le
mieux
chaque innovation devrait être pensés
avec l'effet papillon qu'il produit sur
la planète et notre écosystème car si
nous détruisons les ressources de notre
planète nous créons un monde où il sera
de plus en plus difficile de vivre votre
génération elle a le pouvoir de faire ça
de modifier notre manière de consommer
de voyages et de profiter de la vie
beaucoup de choses qui nous paraissent
normales aujourd'hui ne le sont pas du
tout et le seront encore moins dans
l'avenir nous devons apprendre à
désapprendre il se trouve que
l'évolution a fait de nous l'être vivant
le plus intelligent de cette planète je
pense qu'il ya une raison à cela
utilisons le génie humain pour
transformer le monde et non pour le
détruire certains vous diront sans doute
c'est impossible je sais je vais vous
dire où est ce que je puise la force de
croire en vous
d'avancer et de continuer chaque jour
c'est un événement qui m'a marqué quand
j'étais enfant
je viens d'une famille de hongrois exilé
en france réfugiés politiques qui ont dû
fuir du jour au lendemain leur pays à
cause du régime communiste j'ai été
élevé avec l'idée que le mur de berlin
ne tomberai jamais et à cette époque là
le monde entier le pensait puis il est
venu la nuit du 9 novembre 1989 et cette
nuit là le mur est tombé c'est un
événement qui a bouleversé le monde
entier et c'est un événement qui a été
un exemple très concret pour moi que
tout est toujours possible même quand
cela paraît impossible et que le monde
entier y croit je souhaiterais terminée
par une citation de mohammad ali que
j'affectionne tout particulièrement
impossible n'est rien qu'une excuse
avancée parce qu'ils trouvent plus
facile de vivre dans le monde qui leur a
été légué plutôt que de chercher en eux
la force de le changer
impossible n'est pas un fait c'est une
opinion
impossible n'est pas une fatalité c'est
un défi relevé le merci
[Musique]